I understand you've been a little
unhappy with people that aren't social
distancing especially young people that
that's been pissing you off yeah it's
been pissed I think it's pissing
everyone off who's you know making like
an effort to stay in and and really try
to slow the spread of the virus I mean
my eldest brother and my sister-in-law
they are doctors in the UK and they just
got transferred to the ICU and it's so
frustrating seeing these people like
going out and spring breaking all over
the place like in Malibu it's packed
right now and in Miami I guess and it's
just like I don't understand how you can
be you know that selfish to put doctors
lives at risks who are gonna have to end
up treating you and then you know become
vulnerable to to the infection by
treating you like I think if we can all
stay huh I mean you're literally being
asked to do nothing you know I mean like
that it should be fairly easy it's
almost because people can't see it you
know and if you can't see it I think
there are some people that think hey
what are we doing this is my beach time
this is my Spring Break yeah oh it's
harshing my mellow I want to get out
there I don't think anyone's saying
harsh my mellow but but anyway you are I
am I am I'm 79 years old